my council be seated for a second has a
couple things that i need to address
all right number one uh juror number 14.
yes uh i i was informed first by the
officer and then by my staff at the
break that at some point during the
cross examination
you were able to see a document that was
up on one of the prosecutor's screens is
that an accurate
statement
right okay and you saw it directly or
was it reflected off of one of the
dividers
well
early on i saw photographs right
it's unfortunate this is covered era and
you are seated where you are normally
you'd be in the box and you wouldn't be
able to see anything so i i've
instructed the prosecutors that sidebar
when it was first brought to my
attention to be very careful about that
so
if there's something that's going to be
shown to the witnesses
on the screen they'll pull that up but
otherwise they shouldn't pull up
documents and if they happen to pull
something up just try not to look at it
to the best of your ability okay and um
fine that should handle the situation
now the other situation is i was
informed by my staff that some of the
jurors in the second row may have heard
whispering coming from the gallery
that's completely unacceptable
not that the jurors heard it but there's
whispering in the gallery people in the
gallery cannot talk about the case
especially
because we have jurors in the first two
rows
and members of the jury thank you for
bringing that to my staff's attention if
it persists i will have my courtroom
cleared
do i make myself clear
please do not discuss any aspect of the
case
do not speak about the case do not speak
about anything that may distract our
jurors
when you are in the courtroom
if there is another complaint i will
exercise my authority and clear the
courtroom except for the jurors i don't
want to have to do that
this is a public courtroom a public
trial
you have a right to be here but
the jurors have a right not to be
distracted
by whispering in the courtroom they have
to pay careful attention and they have
been throughout this trial and i have no
doubt they will continue to pay
attention
to what occurs in the courtroom from the
witness stand but they cannot be
distracted
by
members of the public in the gallery so
please do not speak at all about the
case you should be saying nothing
just listen to the testimony
if you have comments that's fine i'm
sure you all do share them outside
outside the presence of the members of
the jury all right thank you all right
with that being said can we bring in mr
goodwin please and we'll continue with
the cross examination
the members of the jury please if you
hear anything just bring it to my
staff's attention and raise your hand
and i'll deal with it immediately all
right thank you
[Music]
good morning before we proceed i'm sorry
can i see council on sidebar for one
moment please
the continued cross-examination of mr
goodwin
go ahead council
[Music]
it's a good one
you
testified that
you
saw the actual
shooting
of foreign correct yes
did you
previously tell
corporal thomas fellini
that after you talked to michael
barriston
you turned
to walk back
into the residence
lauren cataract
walked over
to speak to michael barroso judge can we
come to sidebar
reword and clarify your questioning of
the witness please
goodwin
after the shooting did you talk to the
washington township police department i
did
did you give them a statement
right after the incident as to what
actually happened i did give a statement
did you tell
the washington township police
department
that after you spoke to michael
barrisson you turned your back and
walked into the house to walk back into
the house
that's this is the problem mr blancas
why don't you show it to him and ask the
witness if that's what he said to the
police
all right please proceed
this is a good one i'm going to show you
defense exhibit
100 c 14.6
which is
an affidavit
i'm going to refer you to page 4
and point out a
the portion that's big enough thank you
all right and ask you
to read that
to see if it refreshes the recollection
as to what you specifically told the
police
immediately after the incident this is a
transcript of the
recorded it's an f
affidavit
i'm not familiar with
what that means
it's a sworn statement submitted by the
police
that is not accurate
so is it your testimony that you never
told
the police
immediately after the incident
that after you talked to michael
barrisson
you've walked into the residence and
heard
gunshots
that doesn't say i walk into the
residence it says
what's important in that thing is that
it says that i did the witness not
comment on
what's contained in a police document
on your vomit
now
you observe warren cataract
walking to michael barazone is that your
testimony correct
and
did you hear what lauren cataract said
to michael barrison she said she would
talk to him as she was walking
i'm asking what she said to him not you
i think she
started to say something and then
michael reached
pulled the gun out and shot her
when you say he reached
weren't you still
weren't you still blocked by that huge
bush and could only see from his chest
up as you've testified to
so the other day he stepped forward and
reached out his arms before he shot
lauren
so
no
did you see him on the telephone
excuse me did you see him on the
telephone at any point
no
did you see
michael barrisson's
phone on a table
in that general area at any point
i saw a gun in michael's hands no phone
and when did you see this gun
when he
pulled it up and shot the farm now
he said michael barrasson's about six
three six four okay
and you were standing on the label how
far up on his body could you see him
from that location
i think
chest chest up
so far maybe maybe a little higher okay
so we're about from here to me somewhere
about there yeah and it's your testimony
that he picked the weapon up
high enough for you to see it over that
bush
and fire two shots into lauren cataract
as lauren was approaching michael to
have this conversation that michael
said he wanted to have with us
he took a step forward towards lauren
raised up his hands and shot so
his arms
were to
understand what i'm saying he stepped
out from behind the bush at that point
he took one step from behind the bush
when he shot
he was aggressively well not
aggressively sorry took a step towards
lauren when he took the shot when he
raised up the gun
all right so let me see if i understand
what you're saying
if you're on
the porch
the bush is
approximately what eight feet away from
where you're standing
and
it's
as high as michael barrasson's chest
correct
okay and even though you're elevated you
only see
from here up correct okay
now
it's your testimony
from that position
that michael barrasson takes the step
what to my right towards the gravel
driveway okay towards lauren where she
was standing
and
raises his hand and shoots her okay
now how tall is lauren cataract
five five five six okay well can i
assume you didn't raise the gun up this
high to shoot at warren cataract over
five five i think that would be pretty
accurate yeah okay and
he
and this is based on what you're
testifying you saw the gun was about
where when he fired the shots that
like straight out from his arm as i'm
holding it
approximately four feet correct
props
how how
was his arm raised
because he raised his hand he extended
his arm
and you could see that
over the bush
do we have a picture i'll show of
he stepped one step
forward out one step forward out to the
driveway which was enough to be
unconcealed by the bush 100
and i don't know if that bush was there
if it would block his arms because like
i said i definitely could see his
shoulders i saw his arms come up when he
he talked to me when he came up to talk
to me so
if he held his gun up
you know i think it'd be pretty
reasonable to say
that i saw it still if he stood in the
exact same position he tried to lure us
out of the house in from
when you say
lure
us out of the house
you and both lauren came out on your
free will correct
i think he tried to pull us
to his area i came out to the porch i
did not want to conversate with him i
told him the attorneys will handle it
i believe his intention was to pull us
out of the house
i asked you
when you first observed michael
barrasson
if you would describe him as sorrowful
and
he didn't even
seem like you understood what i
was asking is that a fair statement
yes i did not recall it i don't know and
also you were very vague about it was he
sorrowful within the two years that i've
ever met him i had no contact no no i'm
talking about i didn't know that moments
before
the shooting
i'm talking about the day of the
incident
did you tell the police in your official
version
he looked really
sorrowful
page four bottom of the first paragraph
where is it at
page four bottom of the first paragraph
you need my glasses no i could do this
okay what is that
did you describe
your observations of michael barrisson
immediately before the shooting as
sorrowful
it says here i did and
do you recall that
i don't recall saying this no
i left this statement when lauren was
dying in the hot well when i thought
lauren was dying in the hospital or
possibly not alive okay and at that
point
is it fair to say that you had no love
loss for michael barrasson and you
weren't saying anything trying to
protect him what is fair to say is i
think this is consistent with what i'm
saying is
sincere sorrowful he tried to draw us
out of the house
to hand so he could shoot us
did you say i could only see from the
chest and above and he said something
like he looked really sorrowful you know
what did you just say you believe that
to me
you look sincere in saying how do we
work this out
i personally did not care because
but
my
specific question is did you use the
term
sorrowful
it says right here i said sorrowful
thank you
so
will you agree with me that
calm
and
sorrowful is a huge difference between
angry
i never said he was angry
and would you agree with me that based
on your entire observations
the entire incident
he never appeared angry correct
correct well we just went over this yes
now
you just testified on
uh to my last question that you observed
michael barrasson shoeborn cataract
from the
landing on top of the stairs correct
correct
i was on landing
did you tell the police in your official
statement that before the shooting you
came down the stairs
came down the stairs from before the
shooting yes i was upstairs on the third
floor apartment i imagine i came down
some stairs
can you look at page three
is it your
testimony that your reference to the
police that you came down the stairs
that you were talking about inside
of the house at that point
is that your sworn testimony
so
i believe that's in reference to me
coming down the stairs from the
apartment
well when you said lauren walked down
the stairs where was she walking down
the stairs
in that
specific
sentence
where was lauren when you were walking
down the stairs was she outside at that
point
she was behind me
well
and then she agreed with me that
you told the police she walked down the
stairs to talk to barista
and then two shots
were fired
isn't it a fact you were inside when the
shots were fired not at all a fact
it's ridiculous
now
how quickly were these shots fired in
succession
very quickly yeah let's stop watch
boom boom
okay and then
how quickly after that
was the shot you playing was fired at
you
took two three more steps turned to me
and fired at me so a couple of seconds
okay so some sort of a pause in between
the two two two shots fired lauren
a little hesitation maybe a pause
whatever you want to call it aimed at me
and fired at me okay
boom boom
boom boom boom boom
now
were those shots live
uh
not overly no i don't think so
i mean they were loud yes but
nine millimeter correct
yeah
that'll be a reference question right
well you're familiar with nine
millimeters
was it a loud boom
uh was it wasn't as loud as uh
lauren's gone
did you tell the police that after
he fired at lauren
that you ran
in
the house
did you tell the police that immediately
after the incident
sorry can you rephrase it where can you
say it again sure did you tell the
police that after
lauren was shot
i kind of ran
in the house
did you say that
i dove into the in in through the door
as michael raised the gun up at me
did you say i've ran in the house
again
a second time in your official statement
i dove into the house i dove into the
house i remember seeing the
tempered glass windows shattering around
the floor as i
was laying on the floor so if i didn't
maybe it was a misspeak
i'm sure throughout here we'll find out
do i need to read this
no i'm not if i ask you a question or
referred i'll refer you to a specific
section
now
you see lauren gets shot
isn't it a fact that after she got shot
she ran away
and you have no idea where she went
i did lose contact when i dove into the
house of where she went yes
and
did she run around the house
based on your observations
she ran away when michael after michael
shot at her she turned around
ran away
pretty shortly after he raised the gun
at me and i dove into the house so i did
not
see
if one right now in the house
did you ever tell anyone
that lauren disappeared
and you think she ran around the house
i don't know what lauren did after i
dove in the house
well
you weren't in the house for any length
of time correct i dove on the floor and
i got up and i charged out at that time
michael was charging in okay and
was lauren there in the immediate area
at that point lauren was there because
on the conflict on the porch when
michael brought the gun up and i had him
in a choke hold
she grabbed his gun hand and tried to
pull it down
i assume
i assumed he was going to try to
shoot at me over his head over his
shoulder
but lauren jumped on his arm and held
his gun hand
now
did you ever tell the police that
lauren cataract
was up on the stairs
grabbing at michael barrasson's arm with
a weapon in it in your official
statement
i would imagine i did say that
can you look at uh page three
same paragraph you're talking to
i'm talking about
and see whether or not it refreshes your
recollection as to whether you ever
mention
that lauren cataract and you
were on the stairs
trying
to get the gun away from michael
barriston
so
this
so
okay
not in that paragraph it does not say
that
when you say paragraph
that's the paragraph when you talk about
the actual shooting correct
the paragraph i just read
and nowhere in there did you mention
that lauren cataract was on the steps
struggling with you and
she wasn't on the steps
she reached up while me and mike were on
step she was on the side
side of the rally she reached up tried
to grab michael's arm
from with her feet on the ground i
thought she could have been on the steps
she was behind michael
she was
it was me michael lauren i saw lauren
jump up and grab his hands i don't know
exactly where she was standing okay but
you you testified previously she was on
the steps correct
i'm not entirely sure that's accurate
all right i'll ask it again
where exactly when was laurent cataract
where
you say she reached up and tried to grab
michael barrison
she was on the
would be michael's front side
on the other end of me and michael
all i saw were her hands
and that they were
wrapped around his arm as he was trying
to
pull it up she was trying to pull his
arms down
and and again i don't want to belabor
this point anymore but you don't know
whether she's on the steps or she's on
the ground
i was concentrating on the gun that was
coming up to my head okay and when when
you're talking about this specific
instance michael barrisson
is his back is to you correct correct
lauren canorack is front is in front of
you uh him correct
and have you struck him in the head
at this point
this question yes
and did you knock them out
with that punch
no
so
at some point in time
when the gun
according to you is in michael
barrasso's hand
both you and lauren are struggling with
him
to try to get the gun correct
no
i was struggling to
stop him from
murdering us
okay well
you saw the slide back
and immediately recognized that the gun
was empty before
you leaped out and struck and struck him
according to your testimony correct
so there was no danger in any other
bullets being fired
based on your observations of michael
barrasso
and the gun
i don't know if i was able to process
i don't know if i was able to process
what was going on i was very unfamiliar
with the gun i did not
you know i did not know the full extent
of processing it i mean i watched lauren
get shot
and yet i didn't realize she was shot
until i saw the holes coming out of the
back of her shirt so it's a very
stressful fast time
we'll get to that point in a second but
let's talk about
something else first
you say
you
physically see
not hear but physically see
michael barrisson shoot lauren tanner
correct
and and it's your testimony that with
that observation
you didn't even realize that she was
shocked
is that your testimony
even though you claim to have seen a gun
heard
the gunfire twice
you did not realize
until after you started beating michael
barrison that he was shot she was shot
is that your testimony
she did not let me rephrase it this way
she did not fall on the ground after
being shot
there is a possibility that maybe she
was missed
we could throw those possibilities out
of the way when i'm looking at holes
coming through the back of her shirt
that is when i realized she was shot by
michael
now
you'll agree with me when
you
leaped at michael barisso and
cracked him in the face
that that was the first
punch that you landed correct
now
didn't michael barriston have his back
to you at that point
no he was charging into the house and
was leaping out of the house
when did he turn his back on you
well after i punched him he looked dazed
for a little bit and then
i didn't know her just turned and went
to go
run off i don't know if he was what he
where he was running to
know what he was doing i don't know what
he was thinking
he turned around
and i don't know if he was retreating or
walking he turned around and gave me it
back
and
where exactly on michael barrasson's
face did you strike him
i think the forehead
when he turned his back
and attempted
to get away
is that when you
leaped on his back and started to choke
him
i'm sorry i just i just said i don't
know what he was doing so i'm not saying
that he attempted to get away he could
have been going to finish
killing lauren
there's nothing
that states he was trying to get away he
was a man with a gun on our property
trying to kill us
i subdued him
okay so
at some point
irrespective of what his intentions are
he tries to
walk away from correct he turned around
turned around
and at that point you jump on his back
and you start choking him at that point
i threw a chokehold right on his neck
and
is he still on the stairs at this point
we're either on the patio
i think we're right on the top not the
patio sorry the um
porch
the little porch we're on
top of the porch that point
maybe one step down i
don't know
we're on the porch
so
you're on the landing
or the first step
going down
okay that's what your testimony is yeah
so
is it
safe to assume that when you struck him
in the forehead he was on the landing
by his car
did he attempt to turn
and walk away
while he was still on the landing
turned around
okay and started to walk down
and only got to the first step correct
according to what you just said i feel
like we're having a play on words here
say it again i i just want to try to be
accurate
you indicated
he's on the landing
and you you hit him in the forehead
he turns around
he's still on the landing
and he's either on the landing or he's
taking his first step down and you jump
on him and start choking him correct
yeah as soon as he turned around i was i
was on his neck okay this is your turn
you've got to remember this is a fight
for my life lauren's life
right so
okay as soon as he turned around i tried
to subdue him okay and where was lauren
at this point when he's at the top of
the stairs
trying to
grab at the gun
next time i see lauren is when the gun
comes up lauren jumps on his arm
to protect me
that point we don't know the gun is
jammed
or anything
of the fact like i said
even seeing it i did not recognize it
did not process in my head
that that gun was no longer a weapon
because the slide was locked back
didn't you tell the police that
the reason why you decided to
charge at michael barrasson is because
you saw that the slide was back
and realized that the weapon had no
bullets in it
please show me where i was set anywhere
we'll get to that
[Music]
now
when you were choking michael barristone
um did he pass out
he did
and where's
lauren cataract at that point
lauren counter is on the side of the
stairs
well we're all grouped in one section if
you got a picture it's easier if i just
show you then i explain
now at this point in time were you down
on the concrete patio
i was on top of michael and we were both
on the patio
did you
slam michael barrissone's
face
into the concrete patio
we passed out we fell onto the patio
onto the concrete patio
at any point in time did in the struggle
did you
punch him
in the face
when michael was coming back too he was
very
he was trying to get back up i did punch
him
and i did hold him down how many times
did you punch michael barrasson in the
face
enough to get him to not get access to
the gun anymore do you have any idea how
many
punches that took
i mean this is a fight for my life so
was i concerned about how many times i
was punching the man that is trying to
get up
i was not and i
no i do not know how many times i
punched him in the face
the fact of the matter is he was trying
to get back up and did you
punch him
on the side of the head
in both ears
specifically i do not know
have you seen any pictures of
what michael barrasson looked like
after you got done punching him and
hitting him
i saw him on his first court hearing
now
at some point in time did lauren
cataract
start
beating michael
on the side of the face
with her telephone lauren carrick may
have hit him a few times
at that point she was just about to pass
out
and it's your testimony
go ahead
i did
want her to
you know
want her to stay alive is is
you know
i don't know if my focus was that
she just maybe can press
or hold the blood in i you know i would
prefer that's what
what she was would be doing you know
okay but
did she
beat michael barristone
for approximately seven minutes
during this incident no
how many times did you see lauren
cataract
hit michael barrisson
with her telephone
in the ear
and the cheek area
a few times i've seen lauren she was
also in the fight for her life
okay
she hit him a few times but at this
point she was very
very close to passing out
and she couldn't even stand
so i do not believe there was any sort
of
damage done
from her hitting she may think
she did some damage you may imply that
you did some damage but at this point
she was almost dying
okay incapable of
of
walking around at this point correct at
this point she was on the ground yes
incapable of walking up the stairs and
uh
getting an object from the landing
correct
we're talking about after i subdued
michael
yes you're talking you're implying
before
listen to my question
your testimony and correct me if i'm
wrong is that
immediately after the shooting
you strike michael
he turns his back you choke him
you fall to the patio area
and you start to subdue him correct
that's correct
and lauren kenorak is there the whole
time
on her knees
correct
from when i had michael on the ground
and we all we all fell
right yeah she is right there with us
she's right there with you and she
starts
hitting her with the phone
you saw that correct i just said that
okay
uh
do you know how she got
her phone to hit michael barroso
which wasn't
available to her at that point
yeah mr blink just don't editorialize
please just ask ask the question do you
know
do you know
i didn't
just re-asked a question and don't
editorialize just ask a question did you
see lauren cataract
leave the area
walk up the stairs
grab her iphone
come down
and then start beating
michael barson
she never left that that area correct
at that point like i stated she was
and can i assume that after that
you didn't see her go back up the stairs
again
and get a different phone
and come down
and call 911.
she had my phone
from the minute i walked down the stairs
from the apartment correct did i give it
to her either mr valencus again
you know we don't need your comments
about the testimony it's it's
inappropriate you don't say correct when
a witness answers don't do it again
please
she had your phone when she came to talk
to michael barriston correct
she definitely had my phone yes and this
whole shooting the sequence of events
would
be heard by the lawyer who was on the
call
correct
i assume yes
and
after you
struck michael and choked him
she was down on her knees
close to dying
the entire time correct from that point
on yes until the police showed up
you never saw her and correct me if i'm
wrong
her going up the stairs once or twice
to get something
no she wasn't even capable of doing that
based on your observations of her
medical condition correct
correct
yes
now
did you see
lauren cataract running around in a
circle at any point
that's when we're talking about the
incident i do not
i do not recall her running in a circle
i recall her running away from
michael
and when i say run away i saw a few
steps before michael aimed a gun at me
and i dove inside so
at any point during this incident did
michael barry barrisson say anything to
you
after your initial discussion with them
no
now
when you were subduing michael barisso
did you tell the police
that you didn't think he knew
where he was
at that point or words to that event
after i punched him or after he was
choked out
after he was choked out
and after you
i mean
no he was he was choked out and then
when he was coming back to consciousness
is when he
was moving around and trying to get up
anything further mr balinkas yes church
i've just gone over my notes
my
um
did you tell the police immediately
after this incident that
you thought michael's barizone had
psychological problems objection
hold on there's an objection mr valencia
the objections sustained mr goodwin
at any time
during this incident
did you observe
anything that would indicate that
michael barrisson was having
psychological problems objection
it's the same question in a different
form
it was dressed up but um
focusing on the the question
is not we know you're not an expert
all right so
council is just asking what observations
you made about
the defendant
um
i'm not really too sure to answer the
question
all right ask another question mr
balance
um
now
with regards to your observations of
michael before the shooting
you've already testified that he was
calm and sorrowful
would you also
describe him as
sincere
when he said
how could we end this
my first impression was yes it was a
sincere gesture i can tell you if he was
sincere
or if he was just trying to lure us out
of the house okay and he mentions the
term war correct
he did and
were you aware
and did you personally see
lauren canorax
it's a compound question okay
did you
see
lauren canorax use
of the term going to war
numerous times throughout
the last
two or three weeks leading up to the
incident
no context to it nor do i remember
specifically anything you're talking
about
now
did your dog
attack michael barrasso
when we were on the concrete patio the
dog got out
because i didn't have time to close the
door as i was
trying to control the situation
so yes at some point i noticed rosie
when
me and michael are tied up on the ground
and i'm subdue subduing him
did you see rosie biting michael
i believe rosie bit me as well
did you see rosie fight michael barrasso
yes
did did you see rosie bite michael
barrasson
in his inner groin area next to his
genitals
uh he was face down so i couldn't
no
i couldn't imagine how that would happen
but
now
did you break
michael's arm
i did
did michael pass out at any point in
time during this beating
so mike i mean in addition to what he
already testified about
when he put him in the chokehold you
mean after that point in time so oh
after after after the chokehold he's
asking
were you aware that ruth cox
had a gun at the facility
no
now
mr goodwin
the day before the shooting
when the townspeople were there
at some point
did you take your finger
and form it into a
pistol
pretend like you pulled the trigger
and word
mouth the words to michael barissone
get
ready
not at all
um
i'm going to show you a series of
pictures
800.
852-865
okay
i'm going to show you these photos
just be careful when you view those mr
shellhorn
i think the witness has already said
that he's seen no pictures of the
defendant after this all happened so i'm
not sure what the relationship
uh that objection was sustained and
something else mr blinkist please
mr goodwin
after the police arrived
you had an opportunity to see
michael barriston they are correct
i don't know
what capacity you're talking about
i did see him there after the incident
yes
and would you agree with me that his
face was
filled with blood
i think i was more concerned with what
lauren was
i understand
but with regards to your observations of
michael barrisson
would you agree
that his
arm
looked deformed did you see that
i don't know how he looked after i did
see him i did not
assess him is i think what you're asking
for an assessment of what i thought of
michael after the incident
okay
i assessed lauren my last question
the week leading up to this incident
things were extremely
toxic
correct are tense
can you tell the ladies and gentlemen of
the jury
why
on august 3rd 2019
you were searching
mary has objections
objection judge objection mr blinkist
you have anything else mister balance
how long do you recall uh redirect i
think it will be before the lunch break
judge all right if that's all right yeah
sure we'll get it done redirect
uh mr goodwin you were asked questions
about when the township officials came
to the
did you meet with any of the town
township officials
i
recall talking to them and i dropped the
paperwork off at the um the clerk's
office but i'm asking specifically when
they came to the property did you speak
to them i don't believe i interacted
with them were you at the barn
at any point when they were at the barn
was were you in the area where
michael barrison
i was in the barns of long island
now
i just wanted to ask you a few questions
about your statement do you still have
that in front of you i do and i believe
that's been marked as defendants exhibit
185
correct
that's the statement that mr bulink has
referred to as your official version of
the events
correct
now he asked you at some point whether
you heard the shots
uh against lauren or saw the shots
against lauren yes do you remember what
you testified to on direct yesterday
uh then i
saw michael schumer
and i'm going to direct your attention
to page 30.
about halfway down the page
do you see a line that says sg
so hd in the midway yes does uh one yes
and it says sg is that detective sasha
gould
uh i think she's one of the detectives i
talked with
and it says
she asked you so you see him take the
gun out you see him actually firing at
lauren
and your response is yes correct
so you told that to the police on august
7 2019
does it sound familiar that this
statement began at approximately 509
that afternoon
i wouldn't know what time
i direct your attention to page one
if you look at the last paragraph on
page one
does that refresh your memory of
approximately what time that statement
began
i don't think it's inaccurate
do you remember approximately what time
the shooting happened
two o'clock
so you gave a statement to the police
that was recorded
at the police station
approximately two hours after the
shooting
correct
three hours i'm sorry
my math is off
now you were also asked the questions
about
uh
whether you had walked down the stairs
and off the porch do you remember that
question yeah yes
and i think mr bulinkus asked you did
you step off of the porch and down onto
the patio area i think mr blinkers was
confused about this all right hold on
hold on don't don't open on mr malinka's
state of mind all right just answer the
question please thank you
so my question was do you remember the
question about whether you stepped off
the
porch onto the patio area i do
and what was your answer to that
question no
i'm going to direct your attention to
i believe page 28
and down at the bottom of page 28
where you asked questions about when you
came
when lauren came to get you
i'm sorry
page 28 page 28 at the bottom at the
bottom what am i looking at
does it say detective sasha gould asked
where are you actually are you still on
the how in the house or you're on the
porch now at this point
and did you respond i'm in i was in the
house i came down the stairs i think i
handed off the phone to lauren
because unintelligible on the phone with
the attorney i walked outside and he
said you know how could we end this you
know looking really sincere i mean she
said on the front porch and you said
yeah
exactly
so you told the police on august 7 2019
that you were on the porch while you
were talking to michael barrasso
and i think the last thing i wanted to
clear up was the question about
whether you went into the house
or stayed on the porch at the time of
the shooting do you remember that series
of questions
yes
and specifically
on page
for example
three
page string page three
okay
in in the beginning probably the fifth
line down to that second uh main
mean paragraph
is that uh a paragraph of your your
statements to the police
that's you speaking
uh
it says rg in the left-hand side yeah
i'm just trying to read it real quick
i'm gonna direct you to where you need
to read i'm just asking yeah that's
that's that's my paragraph so that's you
speaking there right yes and about the
fifth line down do you see on the left
column where it says shot at me
yes
does it say shot at me i kind of ran in
the house and then he started coming in
as well
i didn't
i didn't run i didn't ran in the house
just you know because the incident was
going on i didn't know what to do i
ducked in the house and then i realized
like what the hell am i doing and i kind
of turned around
yeah i think
yeah
so did you actually go inside the house
or not
i don't i don't in the house how far
into the house did you go
uh it was a very small room i dove
far enough i felt like i was protected
from
the shots being fired at me
i just wanted to get behind cover
no further questions all right thank you
and
mr goodwin did you also say on page 30
i think she ran like around the house
that's in it
mr blencus that's not
exactly anything about that yeah that's
that's not a a recross question and it
has to be in response to what
was brought up on redirect do you have
any questions about what mr shellhorn
brought up no all right
all right you may step down thank you
please don't discuss the case with
anyone in case you have to be recalled
thank you
all right members of the jury we're
going to take our lunch and recess now
hold on i know you're all anxious i am
too
but
i just want to get back to that issue
about jurors hearing whispering can i
see by a show of hands the jurors in a
gallery who may have previously heard
some whispering
all right
we have two jurors okay very good um i'm
just going to ask you two to remain in
place if you would because i just want
to speak to you a little bit further
with the attorneys okay the rest of the
jurors you can uh go enjoy your lunch
and we'll see you around uh 1 30 this
afternoon we have some more witnesses
that the state will call thank you
can you go out and tell them to cut the
feed
i don't want any of this being sent out
and just confirm for me that it's been
cut
[Music]
all right members of the jury good
afternoon please be seated i hope
everyone enjoyed
their lunches
the state has some additional witnesses
this afternoon and the first witness who
will testify this afternoon the state
will seek to admit
that
or submit that witness as an expert
so i just want to give you a charge i
know you've heard this before my opening
comments but it seemed like an opportune
time to reread that charge to you it's
not overly long on expert testimony
and this applies not only to the next
witness but perhaps another witness this
afternoon and then
likely witnesses next week
so as a general rule ladies and
gentlemen witnesses can testify only
as the facts known by them
this rule ordinarily does not permit the
opinion of a witness to be received
as evidence however
an exception to this rule exists in the
case of an expert witness
who may give his or her opinion as to
any matter
in which he or she is versed
and which is material
to the case
in legal terminology an expert witness
is a witness who has some special
knowledge
skill
experience or training that is not
possessed by the ordinary juror
and who thus may be able to provide
assistance to the jury
in understanding the evidence presented
and determine the facts in the case
in this case expert witnesses may be
called by the state and defendant and as
i said the state does intend to call
at least one and possibly two
witnesses this afternoon who they will
offer as expert witnesses
please bear in mind you are not bound by
such experts opinions
but you should consider each opinion and
give it the weight to which you deem it
is entitled
whether that be great or slight
or you may reject it in examining each
opinion you may
consider the reasons given for it if any
and you may also consider the
qualifications
and credibility of the expert
it is always
within the special function of the jury
to determine whether the facts on which
the answer or testimony of an expert is
based
actually exist
the value or weight of the evidence
strike that let me rephrase the value or
weight of the opinion of the expert is
dependent upon
and no stronger than the facts on which
it is based in other words the
prohibited value of the opinion will
depend upon whether from all the
evidence in the case
you find that those facts are true
you may in fact determine from the
evidence in this case
the facts that form the basis of the
opinion are true
or not true or are true in part only
and in light of such findings you should
decide
what effect such determination has upon
the weight to be given to the opinion of
the expert
your acceptance or rejection
of the expert opinion will depend
therefore to some extent on your
findings
as to the truth of the facts relied upon
the ultimate determination of whether or
not the state has proven defendant's
guilt
beyond a reasonable doubt is to be made
only by the jury
right with that charge mr shellhorn can
you call your witness please yes your
honor the state will call detective
andreas
all right detective zaharopoulos please
well detective please remain standing
place your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand and listen to my
court clerk and minister the oath do you
throw in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name as well
your last name for the record andreas is
a heropolis z-a
h-a-r-o-p-o-u-l-o-s
thank you
i please be seated
please keep your voice up
you don't understand a question
detective please indicate that and i'll
have counsel rephrase yes sir
mr shellhorn you have some photographs
you want to um address first that's
right judge the photos are marked as s
261
through s269
i don't believe there's any objection to
the admissible admission of those
evidence as well as s 3 4 0 and s 3 4 1.
that's right
by those photographs
will be accepted into evidence by the
court
and can be displayed
to the jury during
the detective's testimony and for the
record those are
states exhibit 261-269
states exhibit 340 and 341 all entered
into evidence
please proceed mr shelton thank you
detective can you please reintroduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you work my name is detective andreas
zaharopoulos and i currently work for
the morris county sheriff's office
what is your current rank and assignment
i'm a detective
in the crime scene investigation unit
approximately how long have you been
assigned to that unit approximately six
years have you ever held any other
positions or assignments with the
sheriff's office yes what was that
when i first was hired i was assigned to
the protective services unit which is
here in the courthouse
i'm going to ask you some questions
about your qualifications
can you tell the jury about your level
of education
uh i have a bachelor's degree from the
university of rutgers
and you have any specialized training
with regard to crime scene investigation
yes what was that uh when i was first
assigned to the crime scene unit i
attended the state police crime scene
school which is approximately six weeks
and after that i with throughout the
years i've attended numerous courses
do you have any specialized training
with respect to shooting analysis and
reconstruction yes can you give the jury
a summary of that training
i've taken basic uh shooting
reconstruction as well as advanced
shooting reconstruction so approximately
120 hours of training
solely on shooting analysis and
reconstruction
have you ever instructed
any courses with respect to crime scene
or crime scene investigation yes
have you ever investigated any shooting
incidents during the course of your
career as a detective yes can you tell
the jury approximately how many shooting
incidents you've investigated
i have been to approximately 60 uh
different shooting incidents 30 of which
i have investigated
meaning that you were the primary
investigator correct
can you tell the jury when you say a
shooting incident what type of incidents
that would uh include
i've responded to anything from
accidental discharges
to suicides
attempted homicides homicides
with
with accidental discharges being
law enforcement or of people inside
their own homes
uh can you define the term shooting
reconstruction what does that mean
it's an analysis of a shooting scene and
what are you attempting to do in that
analysis we determined through uh
evidence at a scene we determined to try
to find from where a projectile was
fired from what's a projectile to the
common person a bullet
are there any principles you follow in
conducting a shooting reconstruction
will you science the scientific methods
mathematics physics to try to determine
uh a path of a projectile
are there limits on what you can
determine yes
judge at this point i would like to
offer detectives aheropolis as an expert
in the field of shooting reconstruction
all right council do you have any
questions as to the qualifications
you have any objection to detective
zaharopoulos being qualified as an
expert in shooting reconstruction
all right very well i've listened to the
qualifications of the detective and i do
find pursuant to rule 702 that he is an
expert witness in the area of shooting
reconstruction
based on his education and training
as well as experience in investigating
60 shooting incidents and 30 as the
primary investigator
so he is qualified as an expert and will
be allowed to render his opinion
pursuant to rule 702 of the new jersey
rules of evidence go ahead mr sheldon
thank you honor
detective when you respond to a shooting
incident
to undertake a shooting reconstruction
what type of evidence do you begin by
looking for
uh we look to see if there's anything
potentially uh casings that we might
find defects
whether it be into a window a car
a door a house
anything like that where we can find any
type of defect
does the surface or material that's
involved with the defect have any impact
on your reconstruction yes can you
explain that well each surface responds
differently to force
if you have i would expect that a
projectile would perforate a drywall
i wouldn't expect it to go through brick
uh glass is another thing that a
projectile could go through
are there any particular tools that you
use in conducting your reconstruction
yes can you tell the jury what some of
the tools are
typically intruder reconstruction we
utilize flight path rods
angle finders protractors lasers
what's a flight path rod it's
approximately 18 inches in length
a rod uh made out of either fiberglass
or metal that we use to put through and
we're into a defect to determine the
flight path or the angle of a projectile
and uh
for those people who may not remember
what a protractor is from elementary
school can you remind us it's an angle
uh it's a measuring instrument used to
measure angles
now i want to draw your attention back
to august 7th of 2019 were you working
for the sheriff's office on that day yes
were you working in your capacity as a
crime scene investigation unit detective
yes
do you remember what shift you were
working that day i believe i was working
the morning shift
with that and would that continue
through into the afternoon correct eight
to four
now how does uh in general
csi typically become involved in an
investigation we are a supporting agency
we support
and respond to any municipality within
morris county or the prosecutor's office
if they require our assistance for a
particular crime scene
is the only thing you do with as a
member of csi shooting reconstruction or
do you undertake other aspects of crime
scene investigation i have other
assignments within the unit
now specifically on august 7th of 2019
do you recall if you were made aware of
a shooting incident at 411 west mill
road in washington township yes did you
go to that address i did
do you remember approximately what time
you arrived
i believe
somewhere around three o'clock possibly
just after three
were there other members of csi present
at various times during that
investigation yes
what was your assignment or
responsibility with respect to this
investigation
uh my assignment was to conduct the
shooting reconstruction
as well as to utilize a video camera and
document uh the scene
how was that role or responsibility
determine
uh through our supervisors and the
different officers on scene we discussed
we got together who was going to do what
task
do you recall what the weather was like
that afternoon
uh on my
approach to the scene i was transporting
a uh our command trailer and it was
downpouring on my approach to the scene
now you mentioned uh
taking uh
video can you just explain that process
to the jury
uh typically uh our video cameras we
place an sd card inside
and then
we uh or i as i approached the scene
just video
taped the outside of the home
and then i went inside and videotaped
the interior side of the house as well
do you do that before or after taking
photos that is conducted after we take
photographs do you do the video before
or after collecting evidence before
what's the reason for that sequence
uh the purpose of video taping is just
like photography
initially you want to document the scene
as is without disturbing anything
did you actually take a video in this
case yes and after you did that did you
then turn your attention to the shooting
reconstruction yes
before i ask you questions specifically
about that did you have other
involvement in this case
on the following day august 8th yes can
you tell the jury briefly what your
responsibilities were on august 8th we
were requested to respond for the
prosecutor's office to photograph
uh
the home as well as the barn house for
any potential evidence
and while i was at the farmhouse i
utilized
uh metal detectors to look for casings
or one casing that we were believed to
be on scene
did you also take some photos of the
various areas you just discussed while
you were there that day correct
so taking your attention back to august
7 2019 how did you begin your shooting
reconstruction
i took my own camera and began
photographing the primary scene of where
the
shooting took place with the first
defect which was the the door
can you remind the jury what you were
looking for as initial
evidence
uh i was instruct well i was advised by
detective bailey who was the crime scene
detective for csi
and locate that he had located two
projectile uh casings
on the uh paved
not paved gravel driveway and with that
i also uh had my observed the defect on
the door and that's how i determined a
start point
for my
analysis
is your role
is your focus in conducting a
reconstruction on determining who shot
the gun no
did you observe any bullet defects in
the farmhouse
in the farmhouse yes
can you tell the jury where you observe
those defects the first defect was uh on
the door
then
inside this laundry room area there was
a black mat that was hanging
there was about it was a ricochet or
a graze to it and then there was an exit
defect on the window behind it
did you take photos of all those defects
yes
what's the process that you go through
with uh examining each separate defect
each defect is photographed
uh then i looked at them uh one to one
with uh
ruler up against it just to get the
correct
accurate measurements of each defect
and then from there i started using the
flight path rod to determine an angle of
it
now before we discuss the specifics of
the conclusions that you reached
were you able to reach any conclusions
with respect to those bullet defects yes
what did you conclude
i concluded that the projectile and the
defect to the door was from the outside
going in
and i also determine a certain angle
up and down and left to right as to how
it entered the door
did you document those conclusions in a
report yes
and i'm going to draw your attention
to the screen
i'm going to show you what's been marked
as s389 in evidence
detective what is s-389 a diagram of
that's a diagram of the farmhouse
and is this a fair and accurate diagram
based on your involvement in the
investigation on august 7 2019 yes
you had mentioned uh earlier that you
were aware
of some casings that were located
correct can you tell the jury what a
casing is
uh the casing is where from a projectile
um when you fire a weapon
the projectile the bullet exits from the
front of the barrel the casing whether
it's a semi-auto or a revolver
in a semi-auto it ejects either a
certain way and a revolver it stays
within the cylinder of the weapon
so the casing is the piece that's that's
left over after the bullet is correct
and do you see the uh approximate
location where those casings were found
on this diagram s389 yes can you tell
the jury where those are
they are the square yellow squares
uh in front of the red pickup truck
and they're labeled as mcso item number
nine and mcso item number eight correct
and does that diagram fairly and
accurately depict the area where those
casings were when you were there on that
deck i believe so yes
where was the first defect that you
indicated that you observed on the
farmhouse it was on the door by the
patio and uh where is the door on s 389
uh
to the bottom right of the house
all right i'm going to ask you to uh
look at
s-261 what's s-261 a picture of it is
the photo of the door
and um
where was the defect on the door
it is uh to the right
middle glass pane
so to the right of that uh
the pane to the right of that piece of
paper that says notice
correct
what was the condition of the glass on
the door it had shattered
what is s262 a picture of it's a
close-up of the same window
and what is s263 a picture of it's a
close-up of the defect
and is this picture taken on the
exterior of the door exterior yes
was there any difference in the glass on
the exterior or outside of the door from
the glass on the interior or the inside
of the door there was a difference can
you explain to the jury what the
difference was uh in a shooting
especially when it comes to glass you
can determine the entrance and exit of a
defect
the
back side or the exit side of the defect
produces a cone-shaped or a crater
when the the force of the projectile
striking the glass
forces the
glass on the inside to basically shatter
outwards causing that crater and it has
a rough surface
and did that help you determine the
entrance and exit sides of the window
yes
what is x s 264 a picture of that's a
photograph of the interior launcher
and you see the bullet defect that you
were just discussing in this picture but
from the inside now correct can you
describe where it is for the jury it's
to the left now of the
door on the left side of the window
so between that
pink striped uh piece of fabric and the
piece of paper hanging in the middle of
the door correct
were there any other bullet defects that
you observed or located inside this road
there was one uh well it was
like a scrape
or on the matting
and then the exit which is on the window
to the left
judge i don't anticipate having to ask
the detective to get up and down but
just so he can make clear where it's
hard to see on this picture where the
second defect is and you could just get
down and point it out on the two screens
sure
we're giving up on the laser pointer
we gave it a week
now you can walk over there detective
detective if i could ask you
if you could first point out where the
bullet defect is in the door
okay and then if you could next point
out the approximate area where the
defect is on that mat
somewhere i forget where but it was
somewhere along this area
and can you see the defect you referred
to as the third defect in this picture
okay
judge i think everyone in there
everybody see that
all right everyone see it all right very
good everyone's nodding their heads
detective what's s265 a picture of
that is from the interior side of the
door window
an s-266 it's a close-up of the
of the defect
detective is there any significance to
the pattern
in the glass uh around the defect
uh this
uh breaking of the glass has different
fracturing
and you have
uh radial concentric and concordial
fracturing and what does that tell you
the first type of fractures you get in
the shooting scene of glass is radial
fractures those are if you see
from where the
opening is or the defect itself
how the lines radiating outwards
linear like straight out those are the
radial fractures they are the first
fractures that occur
when the projectile strikes uh glass
what about the other uh types of
fractures the other fractures that you
see basically going in almost circular
around it are the concentric
fracturing
and then just where
the uh defect
is broken right there is the concordial
fracture or the beveling
and is there any significance to those
fractures uh the concentric is just they
occur after the
uh
radial fracturing and then the
concordial is uh the smoothest or the
how the it bevels
now
what is the material to the left of the
glass in this picture that was uh the
vinyl wood combination of the paneling
of the door
and it appears to be broken in this
picture correct
were you able to determine or did that
have any significance to your
reconstruction
yes
can you explain that to the jury
uh in this situation because
the size of the defect you couldn't have
the
a perfect angle with the flight path rod
to stay in place
with however with the correlation of the
other defects i was able to get uh
the flight path of the defect
so if you only had this bullet defect by
itself would you have been able to
determine a flight path no
all right directing your attention back
to
26 s 264 you indicated there was a
defect on that black batting
yes and what is s267 a picture of that's
the ricochet of the defect as it passed
through
and can you identify it in this picture
by the location it is on the picture as
well as if there's anything to uh
identify the general area
if you see right in the middle of the
photo
there's uh the threading is slightly
disturbed
and is it discolored in any way in that
area it's a little bit white
i'm going to show you another angle of
that
defect is that a picture is that picture
labeled as s 268 yes can you identify an
s 268 where the bullet defect is right
there in the middle of the matting where
you see the threads sticking out
slightly
what is that in the background of the
picture that's somewhat blurry that is
the exit defect
and that was the window on the other
side of the room correct
now i'm showing you what's been marked
as s 264 again
uh
did you take some close-up photos of the
third defect and the the left-hand side
yes
what is s269 a picture of that is the
exit defect from the inside of the
laundry room and can you tell the jury
anything about the nature of this defect
with that you can see to the top left of
your screen you have the radial
fracturing and then you have the
concordial fracturing
when you were back at the scene on
august 8th of 2019 you said that you
took additional photographs correct
is s340 a picture you took the following
day yes
and do you see the uh area where
the bullet defect we just looked at in
the last picture is is shown in this
picture yes where is it uh if you look
on the bottom where the ac
unit is right above it to the top left
window pane
and is s 341
a closer up picture of that window yes
detective i'm drawing your attention
back now to s 264.
can you describe for the jury the
process that you
did with the flight path rod using s264
to assist you so because of the the
glass that had fractured uh
i was able to get an area convergence of
the glass basically following those
lines back to where the defect entered
and from that moment that was where i
placed the rod
with the rod i had used lasers
to line up with the exit defect
to get uh the flight path of the
projectile
so are you indicating that you had one
flight path rod in the door and another
one on the defect in the window no just
one was used
and you were able to line it up with the
laser correct and did the laser what did
the laser show you the the laser showed
me the
flight path of the projectile going back
as well as going forward outside of the
residence
and as far as inside the residence here
in s264
did that bullet defect in the door
match the same flight path as the bullet
defect in the window all three defects
correlated with each other
were you able to render opinions then
based on the flight path of the
projectile based on your observations at
the scene as well as your shooting
reconstruction yes
i'm showing you what's been marked as s
390. what is s390 a diagram that is a
diagram of the flight path of the
projectile
and this is an overhead uh
diagram of the flight path yes
can you tell the jury where that uh
flight path is in this picture
it is between where the first target
defect was on the door and the front of
the red pickup truck
was that
bullet defect uh at some sort of an
upward or downward angle that was on an
upward angle
meaning that which end of this line on
s390 would be lower the front of the
pickup truck and the end
where it goes into the house is higher
correct
and so what does that mean for where the
the barrel of the gun was at the time
that the gun was shot in response to the
shooting analysis the front of the
barrel was right where the near
approximately where the front of the
pickup truck was
that it started at the front of the
pickup truck correct
that you're saying that's where the gun
was at the time it was fired
the front of the muzzle yes the muzzle
of the gun was at the base of the pickup
the trajectory of the flight path
somewhere in between the front of the
pickup truck and the door
are you able to give any opinion on the
height of the muzzle of the gun
when it was fired no and why is that
we didn't have uh
height or distance determination of any
uh
of anything to determine that
so i guess does that mean there were
certain factors that you didn't know in
this case to be able to assist you with
that correct
are you able to determine whether those
shell casings that you discussed at the
beginning
are consistent with
or
connected to this bullet defect that you
discussed
no
why not
because with the casings you can't
determine
what type of ammunition was fired into
what created the defect
are all your opinions that you provided
today within a reasonable degree of
practical certainty yes
judge if i could just have the detective
get down and just point to specifically
what line i don't think the color is
necessarily exact there that will be all
right that's fine
so detective if you could just point out
the the line that you were indicating
was the
flight path you determined based on the
bulk defects
it would be between the door
to the front
and that was at an upward angle from the
direction of the truck into the house
correct thank you judge no further
questions
yes
cross-examination
detective uh
how many shell casings
were found
two shell casings were recovered
did you have a discussion with anyone
prior to your uh analysis
as to how many shots
uh were allegedly fired
i was instruct i was advised that the
victim
had been shot twice
and then
the third one to the door
the casings that are depicted on that
diagram
agree with me that there's really
nothing you can
tell with regards to their positioning
with regards to where the shots were
fired correct
because the casings could be disturbed
prior to your arrival correct
were you advised that there were 40 50
people
at the crime scene prior to your arrival
i don't know the number but i was i knew
that there had been many people within
the crime scene prior to my arrival now
did you look for that third casing yes
no doubt when a bullet is fired
that a casing goes along with it correct
correct
but in this particular instance
you or any other
law enforcement person was not able to
find that third case in correct we were
not
now
with regards to your analysis
when a bullet hits an object
the effect that that
object has on on the bullet varies with
the type of
substance it strikes correct correct
in this particular instance
the bullet struck
numerous different types of substances
correct correct
wood one
final
correct and and glass correct yes
and would you agree with me that
uh depending on the strength of those
particular uh items
it affects the flight path of the bullet
as it proceeds through the object it can
yes
and again
your reconstruction
based on
the rods that you used indicated that
the shot was fired from a position lower
than the door correct correct
and it was traveling
in an upward
angle
as it went through the door through the
second window in that launching room
correct correct
but is it fair to say that you can't
term determine the exact
flight path or the exact location where
a bullet was fired from
based on your analysis
it's an approximate location based on
where uh
the back extrapolation of it was
understood but for instance with regards
to this diagram
that bullet could have been fired
from the front of the vehicle correct
correct it could have been fired from
the patio area here correct
it could even be fired right here
in front of the
bush correct anywhere within that line
correct
and even when
if someone was on their back
uh firing the weapon
you can't determine
the
level
at which the
bullet was fired correct in this
situation we couldn't determine the
height
so if someone was on the ground and
fired the weapon that would be
consistent with your analysis correct it
would have had to be closer to the truck
correct
and again you indicated that
although you have
a analysis regarding this flight path
it's an estimate and it could vary
by a foot or so
depending on where the person
was either standing or on the ground
when they fired correct a small degree
of error but yes
depending on the surface that opposes
right
depends depends on
how far the bullet is projected further
correct
can you repeat that
if a bullet doesn't strike anything it
goes a certain distance correct correct
and if it does strike something
depending on what it strikes
that
lessens the distance
because it goes through a particular
type of substance correct
i can't determine the force of if that
actually has happened in this situation
but i would assume it when it strikes an
object some force is lowered
from striking an object and continuing
but in this particular instance
you have a bullet
that travels a certain distance
goes through
a window
wood
vinyl
scrapes up against a mat and then
continues through another piece of glass
correct correct
were you told that lauren cataract was
shot twice and both those bullets
exited out of the back of her body
at the time i did not know
uh
if the
bullets had exited her body or were
inside her body
well
if they did exit her body correct
they would travel
a certain distance
based on what if anything it hit as
going as it went through her body
correct correct
okay
i
go ahead detective when you're talking
about the front the flight path from the
front of the truck there
is that the approximate area where
you're saying that the
gun barrel could have originated the
bullet shot correct and so that would
have been on the ground
for instance here if this was under the
truck correct and then you're indicating
that along that flight path it
goes at an upward angle into the door
yes so would it be something like
what i'm doing right now with my pen the
gun would be somewhere along this
flight path going up into the side
of the the house correct
for the record i think the demonstration
is
a little bit much taller than
well it's up to the jury to determine
that's what's relevant here did i do
that precise angle that you measured
detected it was a i believe a 14 degree
angle
did you determine that with the pressure
hold on what was the 14 degree angle the
angle of the upward this one yes on the
screen correct not what mr shellhorn did
no no no no okay just just so we're
clear all right it's 14 degree angle on
the screen very good
thank you detective detective judge
thank you could someone have been
standing
on the deck of that front porch
and
been struggling and shot the bullet
at that angle
and and created the defects that you
testified to again if it was at a 40
degree angle and i couldn't determine
height determination
nothing further all right you may step
down thank you thank you very much
detective
for your next witness mr shellhorn
please i'll defer to mr benny you're on
your
all right own stitt
hi uh left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand please listen to
my court club do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony comes to this court regarding
this matter should i be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth i
do please state your name your last name
for the record sure my name is william
stitt last name is s-t-i-t-t thank you
i'm gonna have a seat sir please keep
your voice up nice and loud so everyone
can hear you we do have jurors in the
first two rows if you don't understand
the question please indicate that
i'll have council rephrase
go ahead prosecutor thank
good afternoon you steven how are you
good morning
um where are you current employees sir
uh currently i'm contracted with the
morris county sheriff's office
and what position do you hold in the
sheriff's office forensic examiner
um and how long have you been in the
present role of a forensic examiner
approximately four years
and can you generally explain your
duties um as a forensic examiner within
the sheriff's office sure i'm in charge
of the firearms identification unit of
both
case work as well as training
and uh what specific training experience
have you had prior to your work as a
forensic
prior to
i'm sorry could you
repeat the question prosecutor please
sure
what training experience did you have
prior to your work as a forensic
examiner your work experience in general
okay um
i was
trained in a firearms examiner
firearms instructor
i attended two
basic ballistics courses
one in fort dix the other was hosted by
the
jersey city police department i also
attended the
serial number restoration course
put on by the atf
i attended a techniques and firearms
identification
with the fbi done in quantico
several armors courses with all the big
manufacturers glock smith and wesson
h k
six hour ruger remington
um
also a trained as a knight in tech
um i'm sorry i didn't catch that as a
live in technician
can you explain that sure um niven is
national integrated ballistics
information network they oversee ivan
ibis sorry which is the
integrated ballistics identification
system basically it's a database
what they do is they take digital images
download them into the database i mean
they can
cross-check different cases
what it does for us is it can
relate
cases that otherwise wouldn't be
so if we have a
casing that's recovered up here we put
into the system
if the
gun was used in a different crime in a
different county different state what it
can do is it can match that for us
and prior to your work as a contractor
of the sheriff's office were you
previously a member of law enforcement
yes sir and can you describe your
longevity um in that sense
sure before that i was
employed by the morris county sheriff's
office i retired from the morris county
sheriff's office i started in our
corrections
transferred to what we call the bureau
of law enforcement worked here in courts
and transportation
did that for about two years
then i transferred to our
criminal identification section which
included our crime lab and our crime
scene
and how long are we in that role before
retiring
um approximately 19 years
all together i'm sorry all together
server or all together well it's
gathered 25 years
and what's your highest level of
education uh master's
during the course of your career how
many farms have you examined
i would say probably thousands between
department weapons and
casework
and how many of those examinations were
with regard to operability
probably again
over a thousand
um are you an active member of any
professional organizations other than
those you listed earlier
yes
and what are those
one is the new jersey forensic firearms
examiners association
uh afdy which is the association for
tulmar and firearms examiners
and also
the
international law enforcement firearms
instructors
um and have you been previously
qualified as an expert in firearms
operability in the state of new jersey
yes
judges thing moves that william instead
declared an expert in the field of
operation of firearms and examinations
mr blinkus do you have any questions
relating to this witnesses
qualifications only at this point no all
right do you have any objection to
mr stitt being qualified as an expert in
firearms
examination
have you previously testified as an
expert in any courts in the state of new
jersey as an expert yes sir what in what
court sir um i did five times four of
them were here in superior court and one
was municipal right very good under the
circumstances i won't qualify mr stitt
as an expert
in firearms examination based on his
[Music]
knowledge skill and experience and
training as outlined
we will be allowed to render an expert
opinion in the area of firearms
identification
go ahead prosecutor
mr state can you explain to the jury
what it means for a firearm to be
operable that it goes bang basically
and when does it go bang specifically um
after well
specifically sure it's um after the
trigger is pressed to the rear
discharging the weapon
and can you generally give an overall
overview of a general cycle of operation
for semi-automatic
sure
each one was loaded for a semi-automatic
sure the first would be
feed
load
lock
fire
and unlock
and now based on your last response i
could assume that there are different
types of firearms yes sir
and can you explain the difference
between a revolver versus a pistol sure
both of them are handguns
semi-auto what semi-automatic weapons or
pistols work a little different than
revolvers the big difference would be
for the semi-automatic pistols it would
be loaded with a magazine
whereas the
revolver would be loaded through
okay
and can you explain what the term action
means uh with regards to firearms
i'm not sure what you need sir um
specifically a double action single
action can you explain what those mean
and what the differences are sure if a
weapon is single action
or double action single action would be
just one action per press of the trigger
so the amber would be back the single
action would be pressing the trigger
would release the hammer or
the firing pin
double action would be two actions so
basically that press of the trigger it
would cock the weapon and release the
firing pin
so just to clarify with a single action
firearm
the shooter would have to manually
recock that hammer
yes accurate and then pull the trigger
to release the hammer
yes
and these two type of actions can be
present in
revolver scribes single action revolvers
and double action revolvers correct
um can you explain the process of
loading rounds into a revolver
and before you do is there a more
technical term for rounds that you would
use
cartridges okay um and would you say
it's fair to say that a cartridge is
commonly referred to in the public as a
round or a bullet
yes okay
um
so can you explain the process of
loading cartridges into a revolver it
depends on the revolver
typically we see
two types
one revolver would have to be
the cylinder would have to be released
so you would hit the cylinder release
the cylinder would actually slide out
and then what you do is you'd manually
manually
load the five or six rounds whatever it
might be
so typically revolvers in your
experience are roughly five to six
rounds generally
typically
um
and what are the parts
moving back to a cartridge which is the
unexpelled round correct correct what
are the parts of a cartridge can you
explain this to jerry sure with the
cartridges there's basically four um
parts to it there'd be the shell casing
which is basically the container that
holds everything together
there would be a primer which is
basically like a um a fuse if you think
about it there's the powder itself and
then the projectile
moving on to um pistols specifically
um are they loaded in a different way
than the way you explained revolvers are
loaded yes and how is that done
that's done through the magazine and can
you explain what a magazine is to the
joint sure the magazine would be the
item that would hold the cartridges for
the automatic semi-automatic pistol
um and the number of bullets at a farm
is capable of holding
barry from firearm too far
yes
now giving us a broad overview um
what's the steps of operability testing
you take procedurally when you test the
fire proper ability profitability sure
first thing what we do is we
take it out of evidence
we bring it back to our lab first thing
we do is
photograph it overall the reason why we
photograph it to show the condition that
we received it in
then we do a
visual inspection
visual inspections just to make sure
everything looks okay nothing's bent
broken
uh the barrel's not obstructed anything
any safety issues that might come up
then after that what we'll do is
excuse me we will test fire
the weapon we'll take uh two rounds from
our supply our ammo supply um
load that weapon and press the trigger
now you said you test fire these weapons
using ammunition from your supply
correct yes
is that always the case yes sir
so if a farm is turned into your office
for exam and it comes with ammunition
with it you do not use that ammunition
and tests we do not okay what's the
reason for that uh more our safety
we don't know if the other ammo is
uh reloads we don't know who made them
um so it's more of a safety issue um if
they just does come in and their reloads
if we do comparisons that kind of messes
up for our comparison so we want the
factory-loaded ammo
um now moving specifically to the case
of hands um sometime in 2019 were you
asked to examine firearms that were
collected from 411 west mill road in one
valley yes
um and do you recall what firearms you
were asked to remove during that case
sure it was a uh ruger lc9s which was a
nine millimeter semi-automatic pistol
there was a cult army 1917 revolver
a
colt mark iv
series 80 semi-automatic pistol
and another revolver was a frontier 22
caliber so you said there were
two pistols and two revolvers correct
thank you
um
besides the firearms themselves were any
other items turned over to you for this
examination yes sir and what were those
items
there was um
two magazines
and two spent shell casings
and did either of those magazines have
cartridges within them yes sir and those
cartridges were within the magazine when
it was turned over to your office
correct
um you have envelopes in front of you
there's one mark
s-178
you see that
170 178. and so
yes
if you need gloves there are gloves here
on the floor beside you
um i would actually then remove the uh
the magazine from the outfit
and judge once again has been entered
events previously
yes
so
do you have that out of the envelope yes
okay um can you hold it up for the jury
certainly
and if you could just remove your top
fingers i'm sorry
are there rounds within that magazine
there are okay or cartridges rather just
cartridges okay
um and is that
is the state of the magazine as you find
it before you're the same whether it was
turned into you uh upon your examination
yes sir okay
um and did you during your examination
document how many rounds were within
that magazine yes sir i did
and i will be showing you what's been
marked as uh s-360.
is this a uh close-up shot uh of the
magazine as it was that day and as it is
before he said i thought before we do
that mr blinkist do you have any
objection to this item being marked into
evidence i don't believe
no judgment the prosecutor
i don't think that was previously
uh moved but it'll be accepted into
evidence it's item s 360. thank you
and judge also looking to move in uh s
362 um among others but right now 362.
have you spoken to mr bolenkas about
these items that you're going to move in
we've shown them all the pictures yes
all right and no objection to these okay
mr stick looking at what's been marked
three i'm 362. um do you see the rounds
in that picture
outside of the magazine
yes sir and those rounds were uh removed
by you during the examination correct
okay and how many rounds did you remove
from the magazine seven
and again that's how this magazine was
presented to you from the sheriff's
office as retrieved by the scene with
the rounds out with the rounds inside
yes correct
um besides the two magazines
were any other items examined by your
office
besides the handguns and the shell
casings showcase and so that's what i'm
referring to um
with regards to the magazines and end of
shell casings can you determine
if they were related to any farms that
you examined
these magazines and shell casings oh
that's separately so
can you determine based on what you see
with the magazines if they belong to any
specific farm that you examined
yes yes and which farm did the magazines
fall into that was the ruger lc9
looking specific to the two shell
casings um that you examined
um
were those determined
that we established he looked at two
shell casings i know i know he said he
looked at shell casings but
i'm not sure
we established a number
so
set the foundation first please yes
uh mr smith do you examine
how many shell casings did you examine
just examination
two okay
um and before you have envelopes on your
desk that have been previously moved
into evidence
um numbers
one seven
one second
numbers s179 and one eight zero
and were those two shell casings you
have in front of you um the same as
those you've examined that day
yes
sir which firearm in particular are
these shell casings related to uh they
uh match the uh ruger lc9s
um now did you alter any reports um as a
result of your examinations yes sir
and before you have two sheets of paper
should be on the table they're marked
s93 and s94
yes and do you recognize these documents
i do and what are those documents those
are my process reports
and how do you know that um
it's signed by me
and does it fair do they both thoroughly
and accurately depict the reports that
you authored on september 25th and
december 15th yes sir
um judge these are just marked for our
dead i want them entered into evidence
thank you
um
mr st will speak specifically to the
ruger
handgun
it should be on the corner next to you
it's been pre-marked s-177
already engine
177 sir yes sir
and do you recognize that farmer
yes sir
um is that the same farm that you
examined on september 25th 2019
yes sir
and did you have the opportunity to
examine that particular firearm with
regards to operability
yes do you recall the serial number for
that firearm i don't okay um i'd ask you
to refer to your report which is mark
s93 to refresh your recollection
i don't i don't think there's any um
objection or question that that's the
gun that was recovered in this case is
there mr balinkus
no no objection
um and during the course of your
examination that far did you take
photographs yes
and i'm going to show you what's been
pre-marked s 353 355 356 and 357
which have not been offered foreign
what are the numbers again sir
three five three three five five three
five six and three five seven
sure
no objection by um mr balencas those are
in evidence
mr stiff i will cycle through these
photos one by one can you explain to the
jury what you see in s-353
that is the ruger lcd
um and is it fair to say that the state
you see in these pictures how is
presented to you for examination yes sir
and looking back at s353 um
is the slide block back in this picture
yes sir
and what's the significance of that
of the slide being to the rear correct
um in this case it'd just be for safety
issues
and typically when a slide is walked
back um what does that indicate to you
about a firearm
either it's
slid to the rear for safety check or
when the
weapon runs dry or
shoots up all the ammo it will or should
lock to the rear
looking at 356 the firearm is now
removed from the box correct
yes sir
and 355 we see the um close above the
serial number correct yes sir
um now looking at s357
um
could you describe each part of the gun
and its function
uh sure we start from the top uh the top
section is called the slider referred to
as the slide uh what you'll see towards
the rear the side is your
rear sights
towards the front
would be your front sight the part
sticking out of the front would be your
barrel
the bottom half would be the
would be the frame
towards the back
you see the little notch in this slide
to remember that would be your thumb
safety judge
can the mr come down and demonstrate
with his hands where these parts are
yeah you mean point it out on the screen
certainly
yes yes
again in the top mark this would be our
slide
the rear sight
the front side
the barrel the bottom part would be the
frame
towards the bear this would be your
thumb safety
this section here is for your slide lock
now i have the grip
the trigger
trigger guard
and in the grip would be your magazine
lock
and moving specifically to the part you
identified as a slide lock what's the
significance of that part in particular
the side lock again would be for safety
check to slide to lock this slide to the
rear so you can do a visual shock or
again when the firearm runs dry or fires
all its ammunition and it's empty that
slide should lock to the rear
and looking to the trigger it looks like
there's almost two triggers in this
picture can you explain why it looks
that way sure one is a trigger safety
and can you explain what that means sure
um with this back part will be your
trigger the front would be the trigger
safety
in order for that trigger to go to the
rear the first part would have to be
depressed into the trigger and what's
the purpose of that safety it's a safe
it's just so you keep so the trigger
cannot be pulled forward process through
all right
um
um how do you uh load and unload this
firearm particularly
this particular one um
with the magazine would have to be
loaded into magazine law
then the slide would have to be pulled
to the rear
the slide would be released and as the
slide goes forward it would load the
next
next round
and
after having pointed out the parts on
the screen you did mention there's a
safety on this gun aside from the
trigger safety is that correct yes
and does that have any effect on
another step that may have to be taken
before the gun is fired
um it can if it's engaged yes you have
to disengage the safety too far the
weapon
ultimately as a result of your
examination was this firearm deemed to
be operable yes sir
how many cartridges or rounds can this
pistol hold at one time
this particular one has a seven round
magazine
and how many can the weapon actually
hold it would be eight and you'd be
seven in the magazine
and one in the gym
can you testify this pistol yes
um you testified earlier that shell
casings are ejected from a firearm
correctly correct and that's after a
shot or a discharge
yes
um
with regards to empty shell casings that
are ejected is there a particular side
that they usually eject from um
typically it's to the right
the right side of the firearm
and when you say the right what
orientation are we referring to
as the shooter okay so it would be the
shooters right correct
on this particular handgun which side of
the of the gun is the injection port on
on the right side
um do you firearms we have specific
marks on shell casings when they are
fired
yes
and can you explain what markings are
typically left by a firearm on
showcasing sure typically with the um
with semi-automatic uh weapons what
we're looking for is several things
they'll leave
impressions from the firing pin
from what's called the breech face which
is the
part back
towards the rear of the slide
and chamber marks
so when the
empty casing gets extracted from the
weapon it can scratch on the walls of
the chambers and create unique
characteristics or strya
and
after your test fires you also then have
shell casings is that correct
correct
so are you able to then compare shell
casings from your test fires the shell
casings from the ones turned into you
for examination yes
and you're able to just uh well can you
describe the process of how those are
compared
certainly um the way we do it we take
our two test fires from when we did the
operability of the weapon we'll put them
on our
comparison microscope
we will compare those looking for unique
characteristics left behind from the
weapon
we'll do our test fires first
and then we'll use the um
the casings that we've collected from
the scene
and
again you were given what's been marked
as s179n180
for examination
yes
and were able to determine whether those
shell casings were fired from any
particular handgun yes which one was
that
that was the um the ruger lc9
um and during the course of your
investigation or your examination rather
um you took photographs
yes sir and among those photographs are
the ones we've seen so far i'm sorry
among those photographs from the ones
we've viewed so far yes sir
and do those photographs fairly and
accurately depict the photographs that
you took on september 25th 2019. yes sir
judge i'd like to admit those four
photographs
on the numbers again please sure
353 three five six
three five five and three five seven
i i thought we already moved those in
we just moved them in a few moments ago
yeah yeah they're in evidence
moving on to december 18 2019 did you
conduct another examination yes sir
and are the farms you examined in that
time period reflecting your report which
has been pre-marked as s94 yes sir
and you could return the ruger box
um if you could retrieve from those pile
boxes what's been primark s 200 already
in evidence
do you recognize the farmer yes sir
is that one of the farms you examined on
december 18 2019 yes sir it is
is it fair to say
what are the parts of that gun
um
and the function of each
is it comparable to the gun that you
just explained
yes sir this is a again it's a
semi-automatic pistol
and can you hold the box up to the dirt
so they can see which one we're
referring to
and how do you load and unload this
firearm
same as we discussed on the prior weapon
and was there a magazine submitted with
this firearm
yes sir there was
and how many uh
rounds or cartridges does that magazine
hold
this one also holds seven
did you
okay
and were any rounds submitted within
that magazine or handgun
no sorry i believe it was empty okay
and did you have the opportunity to
examine this farm for operability yes
sir
and was the firearm ultimately
determined to be operable no sir it was
not
what made this firearm inoperable during
a visual inspection of it it was
determined that the
pistol was missing both the
firing pin and the extractor
and i know you've mentioned firing pins
before can you explain briefly to the
jury what a fire engine is and what it
does sure uh the firing firing pin is
the part that makes contact with the
primer
the primer is kind of like the fuse
the firing pin is what strikes the
primer
and
why won't a handgun
fire without a pin
[Music]
contact with the primer
and during the course of your
examination of this particular gun uh
did you take photographs also
yes sir
george i'd like to um
mr bennett you'll be a little while
longer on direct
yesterday
um it's after three now we'll take our
afternoon recess and then we'll pick up
in about uh at about 3 20 or so
all right thank you
good morning
[Music]
you can step down sir i think sir
just wait outside just stay down this
end all right thank you
all right you may have a seat sir thank
you you remain under oath
go ahead mr bennett
uh mr stick we left off at um well we
were about to view some photos of
that white handgun that you have in
front of you um so i'll be showing you
it's been marked as s 370 371 373 and
374.
ladies and gentlemen at the break the
court
and council did discuss certain
additional photographs that were moved
into evidence no objection by the
defense and the court accepted those so
those are uh 363 365 367 and 368 370 371
and
373 through 376. those are all admitted
into evidence go ahead mr bennett thank
you
uh mr stick
s370 as it appears on your screen
is how the gun was presented to you at
the time of examination correct yes sir
i have a skip 371 as it is the
same gun removed from the box correct
yes
now looking at s s373
um what does this photo depict uh that's
a view looking down the slide to the
um where the firing pin should be
and can you demonstrate or explain to us
where the firing pin should be this
picture sure if we look down the top
part of the slide you'll see the uh
circle in the background in the center
that's just an empty hole that would be
where the firing pin would
protrude
and looking now to this
374 um
what is the hole we see in the center
of this picture
within the barrel in the center right
there
the one we're looking at there's the the
two holes the one on the right would be
your firing pin hole
or aperture
and what's the hole in the left
that would be where the extractor would
be
and you would state it earlier that both
of those were missing from the spawner
correct making it you know
correct
okay
um you could return that box down to
four importance and uh if you could
retrieve what's been marked s 199
already in
do you recognize that firearm
yes sir
and is that one of the farms you
examined on december 18th 2019 yes sir
it is
and the last two firearms you identified
which were um s-177 and s-200 those were
both semi-automatic pistols as you
described correct
um and is this a different style of
handgun yes sir it is
and what side would that be
revolver
um can you hold that box up for the jury
so they know which weapon you're talking
about yes sir
everybody see that
and looking
to what's been marked as uh s
is that the same farm you see before you
yes sir
and can you describe the parts
of each part in this function of this
firearm and you could feel free to come
down and judge it that's okay if you can
find the screen sure
starting at the top this would be your
bearer
uh front sight a little hard setting
your rear sight is actually behind the
zip tie
this would be your grip panel
your back strap
that would be your hammer
this part here is the cylinder release
this part is the cylinder
the ejector rod and this part is where
it swings out it's called the crane
we have our
trigger and our trigger guard
and i believe you've mentioned before
but can you just watch the very quickly
through how you load this firearm
specifically sir what you have to do is
pull this to the rear the cylinder would
swing out
then you'd be able to load this on
and how many rounds is this farm in
particular
and
we could return to your scene mr
and did you have the opportunity to
examine that firing for operability
yes sir
and was that farm submitted with any
ammunition in it or with it
no sir
was that firearm ultimately be
determined to be operable yes sir it was
and that was done using ammunition you
have from your supply in the lab correct
and during the course of your
examination um
you took photos from this firearm
yes sir and one of those photos is
what's been trump used 367 yes sir it is
and is s316 the same firearm removed
from the box it is
now you can return that box to the
ground please
and um if you could retrieve the last
box which has been marked s201 which is
early evidence
201 201 yes
do you recognize that farm that's before
you yes sir
and is that also one of the farms you
examined december 18th 2019. yes sir it
is
and i'm going to show you um what has
been marked as s375
is that the farm that you have before
you
yes sir it is and that depicts the way
it was presented to you during
examination yes sir
um are the parts on this farm
generally the same as the farm we just
view yes sir it is are there any
differences between the two of those yes
sirs and what difference would that be
um and the um the way you would load it
okay
and judge i would ask just to show the
difference if mr stick can come down and
point to the different piece of this
firearm that makes it unique
go ahead you may step down sir
the previous revolver
did use the cylinder release
but this one is a fixed cylinder
one at a time
you would load it you'd have to spin it
load it again rotate that cylinder until
they were offline
and how many rounds does this particular
gun hold
and what caliber round is this this one
is a 22l
and earlier had mentioned or i'd ask you
a question rather regarding actions what
action does this revolver have uh this
one is a single action and can you
remind the jury what that means
regarding trigger pulls sure for the
trigger pull would be one action so we
want to pull the trigger would release
the environment in order to do another
shot what would you have to do that gun
you would have to cut down
on each shot yes
and uh did you you can return your same
sorry
did you also have an opportunity to
review this firearm with regard to
operability yes sir
and was this firearm determined to be
operable yes sir it was
was this fire presented to you with any
ammunition at the time of testing no sir
and you utilized your own supply to
testify this weapon that's correct
and you take photographs during your
examination besides what we see on the
screen yes
is s376 as it appears before you um
the photo you took during examination
after removing that arm from the box yes
just give me one second
certainly
mr stitt i'm going to show you
two pictures that you took side by side
and we've previously seen already
i'm showing you what's been marked
as s357
and s371
um these are two of the farms that we
were already discussing the examiner
correct yes sir
and
while they look the same do they
function in similar capacity to each
other they do
and when i say that what i mean is are
the same general steps taken to fire
each of these yes sir
however the one on the right was
determined to be inaudible is that
correct yes
no further questions josh
all right close examination mr balinkis
that gun to the right that you just saw
that's the one that's inoperable correct
yes sir
you have no idea how
long that gun had been inaudible
you testified that the 45
was operable correct yes sir and is that
a much larger caliber
caliber
handgun
yes
much more deadly because of the size of
the bullet question listen
please do
sustained
all right any follow-up mr bennett
redirect i mean no judgment
thank you very much
can i see council at the bench please
all right members of the jury we are
going to break now i know it's a little
bit early it's 3 35 currently there's a
couple reasons for that number one it's
friday that's the most important reason
i want you all to get an early start on
your uh weekend
and the case has progressed very nicely
i'm satisfied with the pace of the case
uh it's actually moved a little quicker
than i had
i had anticipated
so
because of those reasons i think it's a
good time to break the state anticipates
finishing their presentation of evidence
their case
on monday maybe in the morning maybe
early afternoon it depends but the
state's going to finish on monday and
then shortly thereafter we'll start the
defense case
all right so you you've heard some
evidence of certainly from the stand but
not the whole case so please it's
important at this juncture not to
discuss the case among yourselves or
with anyone else
that only happens when you hear all the
evidence then you retire to deliberate
on the case
so with those brief comments have a nice
weekend everyone we'll see you monday
morning same time thank you enjoy your
weekend
[Music]
[Music]
all right just stay on for a minute
so mr schoenhorn have all your witness
here witnesses here monday morning so we
can try to
should i finish it
um
yeah i would you have some late
witnesses to call before you get to the
experts where you're going to be yeah
yeah i have a number of police officers
who will be real quick and otherwise
yeah but why don't you but whatever you
want but maybe the police officers would
be a good place to start in the
afternoon
judge i know that uh
mr bolinkis has been working with the
super franchisee about getting those
witnesses lined up but if i could just
ask to be notified
who they anticipate calling on sunday
this weekend
you